it's been 78 years since Disney last
showcased Dumbo's great adventures so
it's safe to say that the live-action
remake was long overdue Disney's modern
take on the 1941 classic film Dumbo is
filled with obvious and subtle
differences watch until the end to find
out why some fans have completely sworn
off the remake opening scenes Disney
released the original Dumbo in 1941 and
it's safe to say that it was tailored to
the younger audience the film starts off
with dark skies thunder and a heavy
round of rain we soon see a muster of
storks soaring through the thundering
skies each stork holds a bundle of joy
in its beak the storks are clearly
heading down to Florida where they can
deliver the baby zoo animals to their
expectant mothers
unfortunately babies are delivered to
many zoo animals with the exception of
Dumbo's mother who looks super
disappointed in the live-action remake
however were greeted by a very different
opening scene although the remake is
still set in the early 20th century its
opening scene is angled to accommodate
the arrival of a small and rumpled
circus it's here that we meet the fire
family who'll soon service Dumbo's
beloved keepers halt fairies children
Millie and Joe greet their father at the
train station however both parties are
the bearers of bad news
hold lost his left arm while away at war
and his kids soon revealed that their
mom passed away during Holt's absence
although the original and the remake
start off in very different fashions
disappointment is a theme that is
present in both adaptations luckily
things start to pick up in the following
act how Dumbo comes into the world there
are plenty of differences between the
original and the remake which is to be
expected one of the biggest ones being
is the way Dumbo was brought into the
world in the Disney original we see a
very excited mrs. jumbo
opening up the storks package one day
late the circus elephants surround the
new mother and her baby and they let out
coos of admiration when Dumbo shows
himself for the first time
despite looking like a regular elephant
first Dumbo soon sneezes and what's his
gigantic ears run free
this causes the other elephants to laugh
and make jokes about mrs. Jumbo's new
baby causing her to lash out in anger
soon her companions give Dumbo his
unfortunate name and rudely laughs and
mrs. jumbo space which makes her even
more furious than before when it comes
to the live-action remake however the
storks are left in the past instead we
watch as Holt finds out that the circus
owner Maxima DC has sold his horses to
make ends meet after facing some
travelling times
this leaves Holt without an act luckily
the circus owners soon explains that
he's acquired a pregnant elephants named
mrs. jumbo and that he wants the fires
to look after it soon the baby elephant
is born and the fires find out that he
has exceptionally large ears but unlike
the original Dumbo receives his name
from a highly despicable crowd no more
talking animals as many of you surely
remember Dumbo and the rest of the
circus animals are able to talk
throughout the original movie however
things are very different in the
live-action remake instead of primarily
focusing on the lives of zoo animals the
remake centers around the lives of
people so if you're expecting to see
Dumbo and mrs. jumbo converse and sing
in the live-action remake you're sorely
mistaken since the film doesn't include
talking animals Dumbo's best friend and
mentor Timothy Mouse isn't a prominent
character although he can easily be
spotted in the 2019 remake his
character's purpose is primarily
replaced by the fire family mrs. jumbo
who could forget the agonizing scene
that served to separate mrs. jumbo
from her adorable baby Dumbo this
heart-wrenching scene is one of the many
reasons Millennials don't want to watch
the live-action remake in the original
film mrs. jumbo is labeled as a mad
elephant when she defends Dumbo from a
group of cruel boys
her actions results in her being chained
up and locked up and she's forced to
watch as Dumbo gets paraded as the
circus clown well apparently some things
never change because mrs. jumbo also
gets sense - elephant gel and the 2019
remake this time however it's the circus
actors who end up singing baby mine so
while mrs. jumbo and Dumbo do get
separated in both films their parting is
mourns in different ways Dumbo's ability
in the original movie Dumbo finds out he
can fly after drinking and toxic eating
bubbles and waking up in a tree however
he's still in disbelief over his
abilities because he can't remember the
previous night so timothy's takes it
upon himself to help jog Dumbo's memory
the classic song when I see an elephant
fly is no longer executed by a murder of
crows instead is the circus children who
encouraged Dumbo to spread his ears and
fly by the time Dumbo masters his gift
the end of the movie is near so in other
words the original movie ends with Dumbo
realizing he can fly whereas the remake
practically picks up where the original
left off in the 2019 live-action film
the fires quickly find out that Dumbo is
special in fact his abilities are
showcased from the very beginning this
allows us to find out what happens to
Dumbo after he becomes the circuses main
attraction the ending there's a major
spoiler coming your way so if you
haven't watched the newest Dumbo film
it's time to retreat anywho we're about
to discuss how both movies end in the
original movie Dumbo becomes the
circuses main attraction and finally
gets accepted by his peers his newfound
title allows him to free his mother and
get her into a private train cart when
it comes to the remake though Dumbo and
his mother are released back into the
wild where they can be free for the very
first time this new ending just goes to
show how much the world has changed in
eight short decades whereas it was once
normal for animals to be caged and
paraded through a circus these practices
are now frowned down upon by modern folk
so it makes sense that the live-action
remake would end with mrs. jumbo and
Dumbo being released into the wild where
they belong
although the original and the remake are
very different they have one thing in
common and exceptionally adorable
elephant who reminds us to embrace our
differences what did you guys think
about the new and improved Dumbo what
are the differences did you spot out let
us know in the comment section below
before you go give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already
thanks for watching the things we'll see
you next time
[Music]